the company formerly known as Blackwater
will always be linked to the first
decade of the so-called war on terror
and it should because it made billions
of dollars off it Blackwater was
essentially a private army a company
founded by a right-wing former Navy SEAL
Erik Prince who made a lot of money
providing mercenaries to the US
government the invasion of Iraq was a
gravy train for Blackwater the State
Department contracted it to guard
American officials around Iraq but soon
allegations began surfacing that put the
company in the spotlight these included
drunken behavior drug use over billing
the State Department that means you
taxpayer smuggling weapons and harming
civilians when the State Department sent
an official to Baghdad to investigate
these allegations a Blackwater manager
threatened to kill him so what did the
US Embassy there do it told the
investigator to leave Iraq immediately
because he was disturbing Blackwater's
operations a few weeks later Blackwater
guards killed 17 civilians at Baghdad
nice or square it was a turning point
for both Blackwater and the US war in
Iraq the Iraqi government dropped the
immunity contractors had from Iraqi
courts and made those companies apply
for a license to work in Iraq but will
you give one to Blackwater in 2009 the
State Department said it wouldn't renew
Blackwater's contract in Iraq the name
was becoming toxic so the company
changed it to Z services but the bad
publicity continued in 2010 five former
executives were charged with illegally
hiding weapons at the company's
headquarters in North Carolina the case
fell apart when the defense claimed
Blackwater was keeping the guns for the
CIA Z's identity as the company formerly
known as Blackwater was hard to shake
off so it renamed itself again in 2011
it's now known as Academy and the
company's new president says he wanted
to be more boring but the interesting
question is
private armies be held accountable the
u.s. spent 640 billion dollars on
weapons in 2013 alone it's also the
number one exporter of weapons to the
world